we have a great show tonight oh my god  the grim reapers in our studio what do  you don't applaud special guest comes I  love a cameo Grim Reaper means death  what are you doing here have you come  for someone is it Andy is it me then who  is it  [Applause]  Larry King Larry Larry I'm sorry this is  bad news the grim reapers here for you  he's here for me we go to lunch every  Tuesday as big honey you go to Canter's  deli you've got to catch you guys are  friends me and him yeah we're roommates  in reform school we both dated Angie  Dickens  okay he is a partner in my bagel place  the original Brooklyn water bagel  company heavily Bravo I get you work in  a play  hey please we're gonna go get a smear  you're gonna smear okay  [Applause]  what the hell happened there I'm hoping  it's one of his fingers right now  this show is so stupid all right  you